hello uh so welcome to our lecture on
the EM algorithm so just to figure out
where we are in the flow because we kind
of have this flow of looking through a
bunch of these unsupervised algorithms
we got kind of got our uh you know hands
dirty with k-means and GMM these were
our first two unsupervised algorithms
and what we're going to try and do is
kind of generalize what happened there
so that we can use it in many different
settings
and and move on from there so last time
we saw these two algorithms kamines in
in GMM if you don't remember the GMM
algorithm was the one that we had these
photons that we were trying to fit
gaussians to maybe three gaussians that
look like that don't worry about if you
don't remember the details just roughly
what we're dealing with and the big idea
we encountered was this idea of a latent
variable and the latent variable in this
setting if you remember was this
fraction of points that come from a
source so we didn't know how many points
were coming from each one of those light
sources that were out there we had to
estimate that once we estimated that
then we would be able to go back and fit
all the different parameters that are
there okay
okay
um awesome so and that the fraction of
points we also had to figure out the
linkage the probability that every
Source was coming from a point and then
we could do the estimation and the main
thing that I wanted you to take from
both k-means and GMM was this main idea
that we kind of guess the latent
variable things is a great way to put it
and kind of how we have in the notes you
guess where the where they're
probabilistically linked that is what's
the probability of this these points
belong to Cluster one this point belongs
to Cluster two so on and then once you
have that you then solve some estimation
problem that looks like a traditional
supervised learning so that
decomposition is quite important and
we're going to try and uh kind of
abstract that away and then we would
estimate the other parameters that's
what I mean by a kind of traditional
supervised thing now today what we're
going to do is we're going to take a
tour of em in latent variable models and
try and cast them on a little bit more
principled footing because last time the
kind of the calculations were yeah it
kind of makes sense that that's the
average the weights in a cluster we'll
try to derive the action that we're
doing there from a more principled
framework which is mle doesn't mean that
it's right maximal likelihood is just a
framework it happens to be though the
framework that we use throughout most of
the class there are others in machine
learning by the way but this is the one
we're going to use so before I get
started on kind of the rundown any
questions there I'll start to write
oh
oh please
[Music]
what is the first step in here now what
do we guess we could guess randomly an
assignment of every point to the cluster
the probability remember there was this
dij if you don't recall we'll bring that
up later don't worry about now but we
had to guess for every point x i which
of the K clusters it belonged to and
with what probability we could for
example initialize that to uniform we
don't know anything right and that's the
thing something we may have some other
heuristic guess that was what was going
on in the k-means plus plus we have a
smarter initialization but that's the
how we get the process started once the
process has started we just keep running
those two Loops again and again and
hopefully it will improve and we'll
capture in what sentence it improves
you'll see this weird picture of a curve
that we go up and that's going to be the
the loss function awesome
okay so we're going to look at the EM
for latent variable algorithms and this
is where it applies this is what it's
for is dealing with various different
Notions of latent variables and I'll
I'll say this right now maybe a little
bit cryptic and I'll come back to it
either at the end of today's lecture in
the next lecture when we pick these
latent variables there's kind of a
little bit of an art what they're doing
basically is they have that decoupling
property if we knew this thing that we
couldn't have observed
then all of a sudden it becomes a really
standard statistical estimation problem
and somehow we are assuming structure
and that's what we're putting into the
latent variable so we're going to see
walking through this today that
structure we're assuming there's this
probabilistic map out there that says
how often you know how likely every uh
point is to go to Every cluster
in other cases we'll see more
sophisticated variants of this idea but
it's it's actually fairly profound
that's the that's the real key idea we
can abstract all the algorithmic details
into en same way we did for you know
the the election the exponential family
stuff okay now before we get started I
want to take a technical detour and so
it's really important that we have sign
posting here because I'll say why is
this guy drawing these weird pictures
the technical detail is I want to make
sure that you understand uh this key
result
which is convexity and Jensen's
inequality
and the reason is I'll refer to this
thing as we go through we're going to
use it it's not like I'm just teaching
you something for your health like this
is actually going to be used in The Next
Step it will actually in some sense be
the entire algorithm like if you
understand this in the simplest way then
understanding the algorithm will make a
lot of sense so become a clear point
where we apply Jensen's inequality where
we make it tight those are the things
that we're going to think about as we go
through it okay so we're going to do
this technical detailer and I'm going to
try and show it to you in pictures
because I think it's the most intuitive
way to understand kind of the basic
cases if you already know it don't worry
it's just another another proof that
you'll see then this will allow us to go
to doing the EM algorithm as mle
and what I mean is we're going to be
able to write down a formal loss
function a likelihood function right
that's what mle is we write down this
loss function and then we maximize the
likelihood and we're going to show that
this actual algorithm is actually under
the covers maximizing a likelihood
function all right
then I'm going to come back and I'm
going to put GMM into this framework and
this will answer some of the questions
that we kind of you know iteratively
heuristically answered like why are we
estimating those parameters in such a
way and that will allow us to say yep
GMM is an em algorithm and so it'll give
us a principle to solve for all the
weights if you remember there was those
cluster centers the mues and the sigmas
The Source centers mu's and sigmas and
fractions and we're going to solve for
all of those and this gives us a
principal way to do it because we're
we're sorry we're in this mle framework
okay so we'll exercise it basically
exercise the notation and then we almost
certainly will not have time for this
today but I combine the notes and we'll
go through that continue to go through
them on Wednesday we'll go through what
we call factor analysis
okay and factor analysis is another
model the reason I want to show it to
you is it's different than gmms so it's
a occupies a different space and it will
kind of force you to look at the kind of
decisions you're making right what are
you modeling here and in particular
we'll model a situation where like
traditional gaussians kind of couldn't
fit the bill because we're modeling
something that's huge and high
dimensional and we have to assume some
structure to be able to get the whole
program to work and by comparing these
two and what's similar to them hopefully
you get a pretty good sense of of what
em is and all the different places that
it runs okay
all right
okay so far so good so if there are no
questions we're going to go right into
our technical detour which will lead
then into the EM algorithm as
um as mle
okay
all right okay so here's our detour
this is convexity and Jensen so this is
a classical inequality and what I want
to show you is that Jensen's inequality
really is like convexity in another guys
okay and it's a key result so I want to
go slowly that's the only reason we're
doing this okay so don't think that
there's something super mysterious going
on there isn't hopefully if I do my job
well you'll just look at the pictures
and be like oh yeah that makes sense
okay here's the line I see what's going
on okay so first we're going to define a
set as convex
when we did this last time but just
recall
a set is convex if oops
if four
any
A and B element of Omega
is that Omega sorry
for any of it the line
between them is in Omega
so I'll write this in math so it's
precise because n Omega okay
so so what does that mean so let's draw
the picture first and we'll draw the
math here's a convex set so it means no
matter how I pick a here's a
and no matter how I pick B
the line the straight line between them
the geode stick between them those
straight line
is in a set this is convex
okay
in contrast just to see there's not a
trivial definition
this thing here which I drew very
crappily but that's okay
I'll draw it like this because actually
you'll see why the bottom makes more
sense to me in a second here
we have one example so if I picked a
here and I picked B here yep the the
line is in the set but that doesn't
prove its convex it has to be convex for
all of this choices and here if I prove
if I put it for B
lo and behold this would not be convex
okay so let me draw write the math while
I have the picture so this is in symbols
for all Lambda
element of zero one so this is how a
parameterized going on the line a b
element of Omega
Lambda a plus 1 minus Lambda oops
accidental stroke Lambda B
is an element of Omega
okay clear enough what that means this
is just the line between a and b
right I'm just saying that no matter how
I pick a and b and Lambda this thing
still remains in the set which is just
capturing this picture
cool
all right now
we're going to use we're going to apply
this to functions
so given a function
uh
for right now we make it uh one one
dimensional GF
we're going to find the graph of that
function
as a set of X Y such that Y is greater
than f of x
okay
f
okay this is my definition
so a function is going to be convex
if it's graph is
okay as I said
okay so let's draw an example of this so
here's my function
here's you know zero here's minus one
here's one and I draw this character
okay so this
okay so the the Shaded region here
so this function by the way the one
that's in my head is going to be f is
equal to x squared so if you're trying
to if you're trying to correct for my
artistic shortcomings this is f equals x
squared it's a parabola it's a parabola
kind of a bull shaped function all right
now no matter how I pick the points and
clearly I should really only have to
worry about picking on the edge so if I
pick a point here a and I pick a point F
of a I pick a point B
and pick a point F of B
the line between them right goes here
it's not necessarily a straight line
across I just happen to pick it that way
go up it go down do whatever once
okay
now this function here will imagine
we'll talk about a point Z later so I'll
just say there's like a point Z that's
going to live in the middle okay and
this is this is B lives here let me
erase zero and one because we don't
really need them their values are kind
of unimportant to us there's just so you
knew what I was drawing okay I'm going
to draw a all right awesome
all right now what is this function
well this is uh I think it's x minus 1 x
minus 2 squared looks like this
and then it is graph
is everything up here
and this is not convex for the same
reason I could pick a point here I pick
a here I pick B here
and the line between them is below the
set so this is a convex function
this is not convex
okay
so let's look at this in symbols so so
clear enough hopefully like trivial like
oh you just drew two pictures twice and
one you said was a function graph and
the other one you didn't the function
graph was open to the top but that
shouldn't be really disturbing
so far so good all right so what does
this mean means for all Lambda element
of 0 1
Lambda A F of a
plus one minus Lambda these are as
tuples
b f of B
is an element of Omega
what does it mean to be an element of
Omega
it means that if I take any Z that's on
the path Lambda a to 1 minus Lambda B so
any character that comes in between here
in here
then it had better be the case
that Lambda F of a
plus 1 minus Lambda F of B
is greater than F of Z
right so this is now Z
F of Z
this is z this is f of Z
does that make sense just translating
the definitions
directly
in the more cryptic language we usually
just tell you
every chord is below the function
I'm sorry it's above the function sorry
I'm drawing the wrong way
above the function
what does that mean
well a chord
is just anything that connects two
points here so like this character would
be another chord it lies entirely above
the graph of the function where the
function actually lives
here that's not case I just found two
points
so that the chord between them is
actually below the function
so it's not convex
and intuitively the reason I drew these
shapes is that convexity for shapes
probably makes more intuitive sense 2D
shapes
but now hopefully you see they're really
the same thing so your geometric
intuition and the function intuition are
the same modulo that we change this
definition here
okay
all right
now
let me see
all right so one other one other bit
here
so we're gonna we'll actually prove this
I think why not sounds like a fun thing
to prove if f is twice differentiable
um and for all x f double Prime of X is
greater than zero then f is convex
okay so this says these functions really
are bull shaped right second derivative
being positive means that they have this
kind of positive curvature that looks
like they use
right they're First Dimension the first
derivative goes up and down but they're
kind of always trending the first
derivative is always getting more
positive right it's negative on the left
hand side positive on the right hand
side that's what it means by bowl shaped
okay
so this isn't super this isn't super
hard to prove but just because I think
it will stall for a little bit in case
you want to ask me questions
I'm writing out a Taylor series for this
F double Prime
let's get a
minus d square
okay plus let me drag that guy so it's a
little clear
okay
and this is this a to a is just
something in a b so maybe you remember
this from
um you know your Taylor series all I'm
saying is I can write F of a as some
point F of Z plus some first derivative
information plus some second derivative
information and then I'm using the
second derivative of remainder so I'm
saying there's some point on the
interval where this is true
okay
same thing for B
this isn't super important for your
conceptual understanding by the way
like this is just to show that you know
you can
um
that you can you know do what you want
to do here that this this makes sense to
you
eight squared and
okay
now I claim it's convex so I just take
what's the obvious thing to do I'm going
to multiply this by Lambda I'm going to
multiply this by one plus Lambda
so that I get I have to make a statement
about this
right that's what's in my definition
above
okay well that's just the same as adding
F of Z for Lambda plus one minus Lambda
that's just F of Z so that's good that
appears
notice here that I get 1 plus a
uh times Lambda plus 1 minus the Lambda
times B well that's just equal to Z
exactly right so I get 0 here
plus zero right this is just because
Lambda a plus one minus Lambda b equals
e
Plus
these things are all positive
plus some constant that's greater than
zero
so that shows that this thing uh this
inequality holds F of Z
please
yeah this is this is Taylor's theorem
great question so what's going on here
if you remember Taylor's theorem is you
can keep expanding and then you have the
last term which is the remainder term
and the remainder term says there exists
some point that lives in a to B such
that this holds with equality and I'm
just using the remainder form of
Taylor's theorem by the way if this this
is really not important for your
conceptual understanding I just want to
show that it's one line that the
statement which is like sometimes
mysterious about derivatives and causes
people's heads to explode like why do
the derivatives connected to the
convexity It's like because of this
this is all that's going on
awesome you can freely forget this and
just use the fact this fact in the
course
okay
stalling done any more questions
Awesome
the real reason we want to go through
the derivative thing is otherwise this
this thing which we actually do care
about
this strongly convex
this definition feels like it comes from
space aliens otherwise if for on a
domain
is if F Prime of X is greater than zero
strictly greater than zero this is
strict equality here
okay that's where the strongly comebacks
comes from or so this is actually
strictly convex doesn't really matter
but
okay so for example f of x equals x
squared which I told you was in my head
well this gives me a simple test right
its second derivative is two
that's greater than zero it is the
prototypical strongly convex function
okay you also saw those one halves
floating around this is to make this
parameter sometimes with the curvature
one doesn't really matter
okay the other function that I had which
you can check and graph yourself is x
squared x minus y 1 squared this is not
convex compute the derivatives you'll
see but it's the one that looks like the
two bumps right that's a it's a quartic
so that's what it looks like has two
bumps
positive discriminant
okay
awesome so at this point what do I care
that you know not too much honestly
about this what I care that you know is
that there's some way that you are
familiar with geometrically what uh
convexity means and you know that there
are these tests in terms of the
derivative the second derivative being
non-negative is a good test for
convexity and if you have a stronger
condition you can get the strong or
strict complexity
okay
all good all right
now what we actually need Jensen's
inequality
now if I've done my job well this
mysterious looking statement
once I show you the connection
you go oh okay that makes sense
it's because it's actually just saying
something about convexity but it's got a
fancy name and it's so useful so it's
the following statement
the expected value of f of x
is greater than F of the expected value
of x
so long as
f is convex
okay
why the heck would this happen
let's take one example
suppose X takes value a
with prob
I don't know Lambda
and X takes value
B
with prob
1 minus Lambda
then what is it saying
it's saying the expected value of f of x
is equal to
Lambda times F of a
plus one minus Lambda F of B
what is f
of the expected value of x
well it's F of Lambda a plus one minus
Lambda
B
that's exactly the definition of convex
the inequality
this is convexity
okay now one thing that is the other
thing I want to to say for this is
notice that this does not matter how I
pick Lambda
later I'm going to define a curve when I
Define a curve and that curve is going
to be as a result of sweeping some
parameters in a high dimensional weird
space but basically it says no matter
how I pick the parameters of that curve
anywhere that lives on this thing that's
a probability distribution a bunch of
numbers that sum to one in the discrete
case
this inequality holds and that's going
to allow me to build a lower Bound for
my function and I'm going to Hill Climb
using it we'll see that in just a minute
that will become clear are there any
questions about this piece here
all right
now you may look and say okay well this
is only in the case when there are two
probabilities what happens when there
are more you can just repeat by
induction you have to do something
fancier if you want something that's a
full probability distribution this holds
even if e is a continuous distribution I
won't show you that because we're not
going to go too far off we'll stop it
you know kind of high school calculus
sound good
all right
so now you know Jensen's theorem and
hopefully you'll always get the
inequality the right way and the weight
region you'll always get the inequality
the right way is you'll draw the picture
of the function and see
the chord's always above it which one
must be Z
which one must be F of z f of Z must be
below the quarter of the function
that's exactly this
cool right now
everything is defined in the literature
traditionally for convex if you take
convex analysis like it's the way we
Define things we actually don't want to
use a convex function here because we're
maximizing likelihood and this is just
notational pain right like if we were
maybe we should have like you know
minimize unlikelihood I don't know what
we should have done but this is where we
are
so we need concave functions and what
are concave functions
G is concave
if and only if minus G is convex
right so we flip it upside down
okay the prototypical one that we'll use
if G of X for example is equal to log of
x here's my picture of log of x you know
probably not very good
is that it's going to look something
like this
go off this way and notice that if I
take a chord of this function
right that's a chord it's below
court is below right which is what I
should hope right if I flipped it upside
down the chord would be above
cool
now also there are functions that are
concave and convex right so what if h of
X is equal to a times X plus b
it's a Line chords are both not a no
longer above and below it's it's
actually concave and convex linear
functions are concave and convex
okay
ends the detour
let's get back to machine learning
okay so now we have the tools just to
make sure what did I care that you got
there you got this way that as long as
we were dealing with probability
distributions no matter which
probability distribution we took we have
this inequality we can get lower bounds
we're going to use that in a second to
draw some curves of a likelihood
function that will hopefully be easier
to optimize than the original function
and we'll try an iterative algorithm
that will look exactly like we talked
about before and the way we'll
conceptualize it is we solve for some
hidden parameter we solve and get a that
gives us an entire family of possible
solutions
we solve on that and we iterate let me
draw the picture after I give you the
formal set
okay
oops
all right so em algorithm has Max
likelihood
that's Max likelihood
I'm just gonna put mle
all right
so
remember
this is the max likelihood formulation
there's some Theta that lives out there
we have some data I from 1 to n these
are our data points
we take a log
of the probability that we assign to the
data
given our parameters this is a way for
us to compare different parameters right
and recall these are the parameters
params
and this is the data
so far so good
right now we're working with latent
variable models so latent variable
models mean that P has a little bit of
extra structure PX data this is a
generic term right this is just one of
the I terms it says the function factors
this way
looks like a sum over Z where Z is our
hidden or latent variable p x z Theta
this is a latent variable right so
remember Z was our GMM latent variable
the cluster probability right so we have
to sum or marginalize over all the
possible choices of Z this is basically
saying I don't know what Z is
I have some probability distribution
that I can compute over my data and Z
given Theta
and I don't since I don't know what Z is
I the term is I marginalize it out means
I sum over all the possible values and
this will get me back a probability for
X right this is a sum over all possible
Z's this will leave me with a
probability for x or sorry probability
for x
is that clear
ask a question please
yeah wonderful question it's a property
of the model in a real sense when we
make a modeling decision we say there
exists some structure out there like
there exists a probabilistic assignment
between photons and point sources you
know one version of the prior is I tell
you exactly where every Photon comes
from that's clearly a very strong prior
if you knew that God speak go do it you
just solve GDA
If instead what you know is there exists
some mapping that's out there then that
structure that you're putting into your
function and what I'm saying is that
mathematically comes down to baking
exactly the same okay and this is the
mathematical form for all of those
latent variable models so when we have
that idea about latent structure we'll
eventually put it into this mathematical
form and we'll see a couple more
examples wonderful question
in GMM this was exactly the Z there the
notation isn't an accent it's the same Z
yeah so the example that we had was the
basically the whole lecture where Z was
the probabilistic linking between
sources and photons yeah yeah so that's
that's one we'll have more examples
later but I want to get through the
algorithm in this abstract form and we
can shoehorn more things into it and
what I'll do afterwards is put GMM right
down in this language we need a couple
more things please
coming from a particular cluster
um what is it expert like what is
probability of X parameterized by Theta
I think actually represent in this case
in that like Photon example yeah exactly
so remember if you there was I think it
was said yesterday by someone here on
that side of the room so I don't know if
that's facial recognition helps you in
the last lecture but was it was like
imagine I was guessing all the photon
models that were out there so each one
was parameterized by some choice of zi
and then what I'm thinking about is what
I want over that is that like across all
those datas no matter how i instantiate
z each one gives me a different
probability distribution I can sum them
up and that tells me given this data no
matter is assigned or across
marginalization cross always that it's
assigned How likely is the data so PX
data we've been using forever we use
that from the supervised days we just
inserted Z and said like well there's
this wild Z that we can't observe but it
somehow constrains X it means that X
like the relationship between Theta and
x and that's what the model does awesome
question
very cool these are wonderful questions
I'd much rather answer these than badly
draw the pictures that come next
we're going to get to those pictures no
matter what so there's really no saving
us all right let's get to the bad
pictures
all right so I'll try and leave this
more or less on the screen
here's the algorithm this is a picture
which you know maybe won't make
perfect sense to start with
but we'll get there
I'll go
all right so remember what a loss
function looks like I'm drawing
everything in 2D but of course this is
in like horrible High dimensions
this is my access is Theta and then what
I have
and I apologize I will use a bunch of
colors I hope this is okay for people to
see
um if not let me know
doesn't look like the most visible color
but doesn't look like the least visible
and I need a couple
this is my loss function L Theta okay so
this is I'll write that in black there
this is l l Theta okay
so this is my lost curve okay this is L
Theta here now remember it's not a nice
concave or convex function right we
wouldn't expect it to be we would hope
because we're going to minimize it that
it's concave that would be nice if it
just looked like this like oh that'd be
so great we would just climb to the top
but we saw in a lot of the problems that
we were after it doesn't look like that
it has these kind of weird bends so we
had to settle that's another way of
copying out and saying we had to settle
for these local iterative Solutions
that's all we're after we settled for
that in kmm for in K means and we're
going to settle for that in GM okay
so how does the algorithm work
we start with an initial guess now again
you could ask
these colors seem harder to read
you start with an initial guess so Theta
let's say at time T so it could be times
zero right this is just the initial
guess whatever it is
then what happens is this is mapped up
to here which is L of theta T I haven't
written anything I'm just giving
notation this is just the value of the
loss that I currently have I suspect
there's a there's something up this this
way I'd like to get
so how do I do it how do I what's the
algorithmic piece what I'm going to do
is I'm going to form so the problem is
optimizing over all those Z's seems
daunting directly optimizing the L's so
instead what I'm going to do
is I'm going to come up with a local
curve
okay and I'm going to call this curve l
t of theta it's another function I'm
only drawing a piece of it but it goes
the whole distance right it's some some
curve now we'll pick LT usually to be
some nice kind of convex function
something that's easy to optimize right
so we're going to try and get that kind
of easy to optimize function and then
what we're going to do is we're going to
optimize that function we're going to
find it's it's local maximum so it's
local maximum for the sake of writing is
let's say here
and then we're going to set that
to be Theta t plus 1. okay
and this is now L of theta t plus one
and we're going to again create some new
curve LT plus 1 of theta
based on that point okay and the key
aspects of the point that I'll write in
a second is this point is a lower bound
this curve is a lower bound it's always
below the loss so it's kind of a
surrogate that I'm not overestimating my
progress
and it's tight it meets at exactly that
point so if I did happen to have the
actual optimal value it would meet at
that point so I wouldn't think and get
fooled that there was a higher loss
function somewhere else let me write
those two
things okay
so first
LT of theta is going to be less than L
Theta we'll call this the lower bound
property
LT of theta t
is going to be equal to l of theta t
sometimes call this the type property
okay
Our Hope
is LT is easier to optimize
than l
so this picture the content is we're
picking these like that was a really bad
drawing of one but these picking these
concave kinds of functions which are
easy to maximize right that's what I
mean by it kind of looks like a
supervised thing then we maximize that
and this is formalizing the back and
forth we take that new maximum that we
have which is our new best effort of
parameters and then
we then do it again and create another
curve now the way we're going to create
that curve you're going to see in one
minute is going to be Jensen's and
that's the whole algorithm
okay so I'll sketch the algorithm you
don't you don't have math to talk about
the algorithm but hopefully it's clear
like what's going on
easy to train surrogate we kind of
slowly Hill Climb with that easy to
train surrogate alternating back and
forth and this is what we were doing in
k-means this is what we were doing in
gmms as well
and just so it's super clear I want to
make clear here
Phi t plus one
this is nothing more than the ARG Max
over Theta of LT of theta means I do Ma
I do the optimization on the surrogate
curve that I created
all right
I think that this description hopefully
gives you some intuition of what's going
on because otherwise the math is kind of
bizarre
um looking
but we'll see so this is the rough algo
I'm just restating what's in the thing
I'm not giving you enough math this is
going to be called not surprisingly the
e-step
this says given
5T
find this curve
L of t
and then the m-step
and together at em
given L of t
set
by T plus 1 equal to ARG Max
by lt5
right so we could imagine doing some
kind of uh gradient descent here but
it's not clear how to deal with this
marginalization that happens in the
middle so if we did like some
marginalization or some sampling we
could do something that looked like that
but it's because we have this
decomposition we also know we have you
can also imagine that we have like a
decent solver for the inner loop because
it's this nice to solve thing I would
say over time this split of like what's
nice to solve and what's not right now
I'm pitching it as you know kind of to
you as like it must be concave and so
it's nice but this kind of just means
like I have an internal solver that's
like fast and I kind of trust and I have
something on the outside that's a latent
variable that I'm like splitting up the
modeling it's it's one of a number of
decomposition strategies doesn't mean
it's the only way to solve it though
wonderful question
cool all right so the question is how do
we construct L of t
and I claim we know everything else so
we'll come back to that claim in a
second
okay so let's look it's going to go term
by term so let's look at a single term
in our equation
okay
all right so I'm going to grab one of
these characters
just one and work with that
okay so how do we construct it so right
now we're trying to understand how to
create this lft from this function
and you should roughly be thinking
because I told you that Jensen's will
have something to do with this okay now
what we're going to do to put it in the
form where Jensen's could be used looks
wholly unmotivated okay totally
unmotivated but it's to shoehorn into
what we're doing and there's there's
some motivation but it's kind of opaque
so let's see what I'm going to do is
something which at first glance seems
strange
now this is true formally
for any Q Z that I pick
okay please
so here I'm just introducing Q this is
true for any cue right
let's not worry about support issues but
like I'm just putting in something that
divides by one seems sort of unmotivated
to do this now I'm going to only
consider
we get to pick Q so I'm going to pick
cues
so that I can use Jensen
such that it's a probability
distribution over the states such that
the sum
over Q Z equals one
and Q Z is greater than or equal uh to
zero
okay I'm gonna call this property star
okay so I'm going to pick Q as a
probability distribution
I'll write that in a different color
okay why because now I can make my
argument one line that's the real reason
so how does it work well okay good
so we have this character copy
and here
this can also be written oops oops I
don't want to use blue
this can also be written as an expected
value where Z is distributed like Q
right
of this weird looking quantity
why is that well it's just the
definition of expectation it is just
symbol pushing there is nothing deep
going on
but it's important symbol pushing
because it means Jensen's Applause oops
log of this thing sorry
damn it I forgot a log
okay I'm just transforming this thing
internally into this notation yeah
please
Q is this function that we picked up
here so Q is just some probability
distribution and this is going to Define
our curve getting just getting a little
bit ahead of ourselves we're going to
allow the curve is going to be
parameterized by whatever probability
distribution we want so it's our degree
of freedom freedom I'm just telling you
something that's going to hold no matter
how I select the probability of
distribution the tool that I have in my
Arsenal to do that is Jensen's
inequality now I've turned this into an
expectation and in one line I'm going to
be able to turn it into a lower bound
that works no matter how I pick it up
graphically what I'm doing sorry to
confuse folks who are copying is is
basically show how to construct this LT
that's always a lower bound everywhere
and that's where I'm going to use
Jensen's inequality so let's see that
next line we'll come back to this
so this is less than I can pull the
expectation out
p x z
ETA over Q Z
this is Jensen
okay
log is concave
this is equal to
sum Q Z
times
log
p x z Theta
Q Z again just simple pushing okay so
there's only one content line here
okay
the key
holds
for any
Q
satisfying star
okay
no matter how I pick the probability
distribution
this chain of reasoning goes through
please
I believe the expectation yeah so this
was exactly Jensen's inequality so if I
scroll back up
this was Jensen's inequality but because
I was applying it to the the negative of
it it's exactly the same piece right it
reverses the inequality
and so I'm just I'm directly applying
that reasoning
oh this thing into this thing yeah yeah
sorry so this is just because Q of Z is
a discrete distribution and the
definition of expectation is this is a
bunch of numbers that sum to one so this
is the dis this is an expectation with
respect to some distribution in
particular the one where z i occurs with
probability Q of Z
see I that's it it's again just simple
pushing please
[Music]
yeah so you want to know how we ground
it into an example is that what you're
asking
no no so there's no Phi here so
apologies if there's something difficult
to read there's a Theta here there's
this new q that I've introduced Q is
something that I've artificially
introduced and I'm just saying that like
I've just proved all I've shown here is
that I have a way of uh if you pick a
cue that satisfies this I have a I have
a way of lower bounding this function
getting a family of lower bounds to it
and I'm trying to give you the intuition
of why I might want to do it it's so
that I can construct those curves that
come later because now this function is
going to be much nicer to optimize but
we haven't quite gotten there yet
awesome
okay so this is gonna this whole thing
is this gives a family this is just what
I was saying there so you're you're
right right ahead of it this gives a
family of lower bounds
namely this is how I get L of T Theta
less than L Theta because term by term
it's going to be low it's going to be
less than or equal to
now it's not it doesn't satisfy all our
requirements because we have to make it
tight
so how do we make it tight that's the
next piece
but right now I have a way of going term
by term from the likelihood function and
getting lower Bounds at a particular
spot and it'll be a lower bound no
matter where I am
but I have to pick a certain cue to make
this operational that's the piece so I
have freedom and pick q and I'm going to
pick a very specific cue and that's
going to give me a lower bound and
that's going to allow me to get the
curve good
yeah yeah so I said I was going to
ignore the support we can imagine just
for the sake of this lecture that it's
strictly greater than zero so I don't
run into weird things about what I mean
by divide by zero here because I'm
controlling the multiplication in a head
at a time like it does make sense but
like you're right to point that out so
just just think about it as greater than
zero yeah wonderful question
cool all right
all right so now how do we make it tight
so what we have to do
the ins the the intuition here is that
we want to make Jensen's inequality
tight and the idea is if what's inside
is constant imagine there was a constant
inside that this term was constant for
all the different values of Z the
expectation clearly doesn't matter
right so if they were all the same then
these two would actually be equal to one
another right this is some value Alpha
and then you would get a sum over all
the alphas that were there they would
sum to one boom done if they all have
the same value here Alpha they would sum
they would uh they would be here in the
log and they would also sum in the same
exact way so as long as this term is a
constant that is it doesn't depend on Z
I'm in business
right so what that means is I want to
pick Q such that log P of x z Theta
over Q Z equals c now before I had all
kinds of freedoms to pick whatever cue I
wanted now
this is where the probability comes in
so Q Z has to be related in some way to
p x of Z for this to work go ahead
uh what is z or C oh c is some constant
this is a this is a constant independent
of the uh you know just for some
constancy
it does not depend on Z
independent of Z
we don't care what its value is we just
care that it doesn't depend on Z in
anyway and then it will be exact
equality
then Jensens will be equality
okay
all right so what is the Natural Choice
well it's that Q Z
should equal p of Z
given X Theta
why is that
well this is also equal to
so
this is because P of X of Z
of theta
equals P of z x Theta
P of X Theta
so if I plug these in
they cancel out
and C is equal to
log p x of theta
okay
so let me make sure this is clear note
this just means note well and B I just
reuse it reflexively just a signal QB
does
depend on
Theta and X
so we're going to have this notation q i
of Z because it depends on each
different value so each data point is
going to get its own different Q which
is the log of How likely this thing is
okay
and we pick those
for each eye so we're because we did
this term by term we can pick that Q q1
Q2 Q3 all different and we pick them all
so they satisfy this equation
okay
this thing has a very famous name so
I'll write that while I was kind of
stall for more questions so what we've
defined here
it's called the evidence-based lower
bound
or the elbow which actually has a fairly
like if you say elbow to a machine
learning person they actually know what
it is nothing we're making up it's a
real thing
so the elbow
of x q Z
equals the sum over Z
Q Z
log
p x c
Theta
over Q Z
okay
and what we've shown
is that L Theta
is less than or equal to or is greater
than or equal to the sum because we did
this term by term
of the elbow
of X of I
Q of I
Theta
sorry this is incorrect notation this is
Theta sorry the Z is marginalized away
the Z can appear again
okay
for any
QR
satisfying stock
sound good
that was just restating the lower bound
all I said is we went turn by turn
through this thing so it holds for every
term that we can pick Qi as long as it's
a probability distribution it's a lower
bound
and then we also showed that L Theta t
equals
sum I 1 to n
oboe
x i
q i
Theta t
for the choice of q i above
okay
so hopefully that picture makes sense
again just to recap what's going on here
we have this opportunity to pick these
these bounds and we'll use them in a
second so hopefully become more clear
exactly what we're kind of optimizing
for here
what we're going to do is you'll see how
we picked the qis and all the rest in a
second but this is basically saying that
it satisfies the two properties that we
had before we're going to pick where we
are on the curve we're going to find
this Con this kind of you know bull
shape upside down thing we're
going to then optimize that thing in a
second pick our new Theta T and then
repeat and do another curve
all right so let's let's do the wrap up
and state the algorithm now with our our
newly hard-earned language
oh no so this is the these are both on
the original loss these are just saying
these are this is the LT here capital l
this is each one of these is capital L
basically right and then this one here
is saying that at the particular point
for that teeth instantiation this is
where we are yeah
all right so the wrap up is as follows
this is how this is what we can now
write down the algorithm in the kind of
full generality with mathematical
Precision although it may still be a
little bit opaque we set Qi of Z in the
E step equal to the probability that z i
given x i and Theta
okay 4i equals 1 to n
okay so this says that you're going to
pick the QI distribution that says you
know what's the probability that's kind
of you know uh most informal or the
exact probability that comes from your
model knowing the data and the current
guess of your parameters right so you
have some Theta at some time you plug it
in you know the data point that you're
looking at you condition on that you say
what are the most likely values of the
cluster linkage as we were talking about
before the source linkage for this
particular point you get a probability
distribution over those you set them to
qiz that's really what's going on it's
your estimate of How likely that is
then
you take an m-step
Theta t plus one
equals
ARG Max
over Theta of LT Theta
which equals
so LT Theta sorry like this
LT theta equals this elbow sum
x i
the QI data okay your current guess of
parameters so basically what it's saying
is you give me a current guess of
parameters I get the lower bound that's
underneath the covers then I optimize
that lower bound surrogate I get the
Theta t plus one that gives me a new
guess of parameters which defines yet a
new curve a Qi for each one of what's
going on then I go back yeah please
Q oh sorry yeah good call
q i
and this is Theta and I'm inconsistent
with the semicolons too so you move this
so there's a good distance distance this
is an X this is a Q This is a Theta
awesome
please right
so it just as before T starts at zero we
have that initial guess let me go from
there
Theta is our current yes
all right why does this terminate
and it's basically for something that's
kind of not very interesting or
satisfying
but it does
this gives you a sequence
that is monotonically increasing or
non-decreasing
okay so it's possible that it would
grind to to a halt but eventually like
you know it has to be strict or some
other things about how fast it
terminates but it's not it's gonna it's
a monotone sequence so we'll have a
convergent subsequence it's really all
that matters
we don't say how fast it converges it's
a separate issue
is it globally optimal well no
no just look at the picture
and so to derive a counter example you
would just find a likelihood function
that had those two bumps and you would
run it in a particular lower bound
setting and what it will do is it will
gradually Hill Climb and this this is
actually not great like it can't go back
downhill right it's got to just continue
to go up if it gets locked inside one of
those bumps it's kind of toast
so in summary what we saw here is
we derived
em
as Emily
okay as promised
okay so just to recap what happened here
we started with this notion around
Jensen's and convexity so we looked at
pictures of convexity and we got an
intuition of what sets our convex and
what sets are not we wanted to use
concave functions which are these kind
of downward facing things the chords are
always below them okay those are the
loss functions because we wanted to
maximize them
the reason that was important is we had
to do this back and forth iteration
given a set of parameters we were going
to find a surrogate that surrogate was
going to be concave in our setting it's
going to be one of those nice functions
that we were after
we would use Jensen's inequality as a
way of constructing that entire curve we
needed the entire curve because we
wanted to optimize it so it wasn't
enough to find a point in a lower bound
we needed to find the whole thing that
was underneath it so we could run our
ARG Max step and that was the setting
where we learned all the parameters and
estimate that in a way that was
hopefully nice and easy to do right
which was like you know estimate the
means and the variance of the data that
we're given we'll run through an example
of that this is a necessarily kind of
abstract and confusing algorithm the
best way to understand it is just to run
it through a couple of the different
examples em and the next one factor
analysis and by the end you'd be like
okay that makes sense it's a lot of
notation because we're abstracting out a
huge number of things that we're doing
okay but in the end
it's not so bad right you take the qis
in this way
except the thetas
do dissent on them or sent on this case
do arguments
okay
all right so let's see it for our uh
gaussian mixture model
please
uh so the termination condition is not
really important or in the classical
sense the thing is is that it's non it's
non-uh decreasing so that like
eventually there's a convergent
subsequence of it and not telling you
how fast it converges for example and it
converges for the same reasons that gmms
converge that we were like kind of going
downhill if you remember it every time
like there was some loss functional that
was decreasing and this is just saying
there's something that's continually
increasing when do you terminate it
operationally like you're running this
algorithm when do you decide you look
and see if the loss of the likelihood
function is not changing too much what
is too much depend on depends on your
data depends on the problem like
sometimes point one is good enough if
you have a huge amount of data and
you're averaging over billions of
examples sometimes if you have uh you
know only a a small amount of data you
want to get to like machine precision
and 10 to the minus 16. and so that's
the way you decide when to do it this
just says that it's not going to
oscillate wildly it's a very weak
statement what I'm making yeah please
part of this is linked to the mle sort
of aspect of it oh awesome yeah so we're
gonna see the mle when we actually do
the the computation here the reason it's
linked to mle comes from a very simple
piece which is we started in this model
where we were saying the way we're going
to think about the world was to maximize
the likelihood and that was like how we
think about our data that's less
disturbing to this group than it is so
like I guess generally worldwide who
think about this because like this is
the only framework we've used in the
course but that's what I mean we started
with L Theta as what we were optimizing
and then we derived this as a set of
concerns we didn't get to a global
Optimum so I don't mean that like we
definitely guaranteed that we got the
maximum likelihood estimation just that
you can phrase what's going on as mle
and so when you get into other
estimation problems and the sub problems
you just apply the mle stuff you learned
from the first half of the class and
we'll see that in an example does that
make sense awesome thank you for the
question please
uh
oh it's tight because we went through
this this small piece here which was
that if we selected it as a constant in
this particular way so before we could
pick any q and it was a lower bound as
long as we did this then actually this
line was no longer an inequality but was
actually exact equality
and it depended though that selection of
Q depends on Theta and X
awesome great question
yeah and that's just making sure that
the picture in your head is exactly
right we go up to the loss curve we get
something that's underneath it that
touches at that one point and then any
optimization we do there is actually
also optimization on the loss curve
itself
cool all right
um
four
mixtures of gaussians or we call them
GMM sorry
all right
all right so what's the e-step
huh
yeah I'm just going to copy down the
thing because let's get the generic
algorithms let me get the generic
algorithm
all right
all right just so we have it on the
screen
so where's our warm-up
not really a warm-up because we're
almost out of time but here's remember
if we saw how this worked P x y i and z
i
remember we factored it as a following
this is just Bayes rule nothing nothing
crafty going on here not tricky
zi was a multinomial
okay this means Phi I
greater than zero sum Phi I
equals one
okay and this was remember our in
cluster J and so then once we knew
given zi equals J then every cluster had
a different shape
so we had a different mean mu J and a
different size or a variance mu J and
I'm doing everything in one dimension
but in two Dimensions you would have
actually the whole covariance would be
different these are the cluster size
descriptions cluster means
okay
right zi is our latent variable
all right
so let's take a look what does em
actually do here
so what does he know
em is very general you can instantiate
it right so what does it mean here
so Q uh I
of Z
is going to be equal to p z i
equals J
given
x i and
so forth
okay now
what actually happened here when we
wanted to understand
what was the probability this is this is
the probability that I the ith component
belongs in J given what we've observed
about x i and what we know about the
cluster shapes and their frequencies
so if you remember we had this this
diagram that I drew quite poorly the
last time that said we had these two
bumps which were our two gaussians let's
say in one Dimensions that look like
this
this was mu 2.
Sigma 2 square
this was mu1
Sigma 1 square
and the question is you give me a point
here
this is my x i
How likely is it to belong to one or two
cluster one or two
right that's basically what we're asking
what's the probability that this point
this ith Point here comes from one or
two now remember
if we just looked at this and these
points and these two distributions were
equal where the the fives were equal
that is both sources were generating the
same amount of information then we would
say oh it's probably much more likely it
belongs to this function cluster one
then cluster two
but if we knew
if we knew
say
on the other hand
if we knew Phi 2 was hugely bigger than
Phi 1.
right a billion points came from the
second source and only one point came
from the First Source
we'd probably say it's more likely that
it would go to this
right it would certainly boost its
probability so now the question is how
do we automate that reasoning and that
is Bayes rule
more likely
and two
so the automate this this is Bayes rule
this is all we did last time
Bayes rule
it just weighs those two probabilities
and tells us what should happen
that's it
okay we ran through exactly those
calculations last time
right
let's take a look at the m-step now
in the m-step we have to compute
derivatives
I want to highlight only one thing here
because it's something that causes
people pain when they do their homeworks
we have to compute derivatives so we're
maximizing here over all the parameters
Phi and mu and sigma Sigma is sorry all
the covariances so these are the sigmas
lowercase and the notation above
these are all Theta or all yeah all
Theta right so Theta is refers to all
the parameters of the problem we were
breaking it out into mues and sigmas and
fives those are all the things we're
observing everything that's non-latent
that's observed not hidden to us
and when we were maximizing over from
our elbow lower bound
was this
sum over z i
q i
z i
log
p x of I
see I
Theta over
q i of z i
okay this whole thing
we're going to call Fi
this is f i of theta
okay hides a time in our notation
all right
so this thing is
let's write it out because the Gory
details will help us oh please there's a
question
he is just latent so I'm giving you the
intuition that's something that's hidden
or not observed but formally it's just
going to be anything that's a z z is
latent that's our definite
please foreign
exactly right yeah this is exactly the
instantiation of what we had above we
reasoned about this through ad hoc
reasons last time but it is exactly the
elbow that we're now going to minimize
with derivatives and to make it concrete
I am either going to waste a bunch of
your time or something will snap in your
head and see how these things put
together I'm going to write out exactly
what f i Theta is so that you can see
like what the derivatives are that you
will compute on this thing because right
now it's probably pretty mysterious to
you like there's elbows and there's peas
and there's cues and like you can just
write this thing down in computers
derivatives and that's that's what you
do I mean that's how this this whole
method works just abstracted it like
three orders of magnitude more than it
should be
okay
so let's see that piece oh please
yeah that's gonna be so I'm just using
that annotation to make sure it's clear
that it depends on the eye it's actually
just a z that you're summing over and
it's summing over for example uh like
we're imagining that it's discrete to
make our notation a little bit nicer it
would be summing over all of the
different clusters that are possible
there all the different sources How
likely are you to be in cluster one two
three four five so on you could also
we'll see later replace it with an
integral if you had something really
fancy that was there like if you had a
continuous distribution over the hidden
States yeah
Frenzy
what to feed us fee is greater than you
know
one source of culture yeah yeah so it is
in fact because of this right here which
I kind of glossed over Qi is exactly
setting that is extending this function
so I gloss over this really really
quickly because it was the same
calculation we did last time pzij to
compute that we remember we expanded it
by Bayes rule we had two different
components we had if you knew you were
in a cluster How likely is the data
point and then we had a term that said
How likely is the cluster and those were
the two functions that we put in and
broke down by Bayes rule it's exactly
the same you've got it perfectly
yeah
all right so let me write out this
monstrosity just because it'll be
potentially it has it has been in the
past educational who knows if it's
educational in the future
in the future being like two seconds
from now
all right I'm going to use a notation
and hopefully it doesn't confuse you uh
Qi equals ZJ so this is the the piece
there so this is the weight this wi is
the same wi we had before I'm sure
you're intimately familiar with all the
notation I use in the GMM lecture but
it's the same w i j that we had before
it's the weight that summarizes this
probability just so I don't have to
write that whole thing up
okay
all right so f i
of theta is going to be equal to the sum
over J because now I'm summing over the
cluster centers right the zi notation
was still very abstract wji which was
summing over this part here
log
and help us all 1 over 2 pi
this is the covariance one-half
this is the x of one half x i
mu J
Square
well I decided to write this in
for General things why do I care about
that oh I see why okay
transpose
Sigma inverse
X I mu J
times
by J oh I just missed it oh that hurts
all right let me scoot
so much better here on a whiteboard
that's really catastrophic
5j okay let me make sure the brackets
are clear I'm going to highlight the
brackets like it's a syntax editor so
make sure they're all there where
they're supposed to be this blue goes
with that one so on okay great and that
means I'm missing a log perfect
all right
not so bad oh and this whole thing is
unfortunately
snap two yeah
over w i j
right that's just
this piece is this piece
this piece here this is the probability
this is the gaussian remember from our
model let's go back up here sorry for
all the scrolling this is our gaussian
here
this is the calcium distribution with
Center J I did use a higher dimensional
covariance because it's something you're
going to have to compute so I've gone
from 1D to higher Dimensions the
notation doesn't change except for this
is what the gaussian looks like instead
of a square you you know that already
and then there's there's the Phi J which
is just multiplied times this you know
horrible expression and this x
parenthesis is so I don't have to write
it in superscript right just expert the
function just a bad habit that I always
use brackets for this
it's historical and I would love to beat
it out of myself if it were possible
please
uh right now the covariance does not
depend on Z in our model the covariance
here oops the covariance here is
something that's that it depends on
which cluster right so it depends on J
sorry I just want to make sure I
understand what you got yeah so I think
if it means it depends on J yes the
covariance could have different shapes
sign can be long and skinny some could
be short and round yeah those depend on
J so this thing here is a very polite
way of saying this guy here should
depend on J
yeah good catch
all right so now
we can compute some some fun derivatives
okay so let's compute
mu J
of f i of theta
okay we have to estimate the mean right
now
and I'm going to do actually I'm going
to do something slightly harder so
apologies if you wrote that down let's
do this there'll be just one extra line
because it's all linear I'm going to sum
over all the data one to n okay
so what this becomes is I sum equals 1
to n this is over all the data I get mu
J
here mu J
times and then it's going to be WJ and
I'm going to drop terms inside the log
that obviously have nothing to do with
mu J
one half X mu J there's I
uh T Sigma inverse J
x i j
all right
and so just so you're clear what's going
on here the log you know turns these
these multiplications into additions so
when I take derivatives like this
doesn't show up anywhere because it does
Sigma doesn't depend on it and that
means sorry it doesn't depend on mu and
this doesn't depend on mu either so I'm
left with these terms
please go ahead
just the term here and a function it is
it is the likelihood function after
we've picked Q at the particular
iteration so it's just notation so I
don't have to write this monstrosity
every time
I kept it
um
yeah wda doesn't have anything to do
with uh Lambda J
so it should be crossed out
is that true let me make sure I'm gonna
mix something something crazy here
no it shouldn't have anything to do with
it
but it will be multi sorry all right I
see what's going on
this is this is what's going on this is
one half and this is a minus w a j is
multiplied by it wij is uh take the
derivative of the log it's going to be
this times this thing plus yeah sorry
thank you for the the notational issue
yeah
cool
all right
we're in business so what happens now
well some mechanics that almost
certainly will introduce bugs and you
will catch and it'll be great that's
that's learning happening there and me
making mistakes
okay so when we actually compute this
this is going to be Sigma J
x i minus mu J
you computed this a bunch of times
all right so
um
yeah all good so we can so when can we
pull this thing out that's repeated
because it's full rank we can pull it
out and and it's linear and we can it
doesn't change anything so we want to
set this to zero
and use
that Sigma J inverse Sigma J is full
rank that will become clear in a second
why that matters so much
because when we pull it out what do we
get we get here
Sigma J
uh inverse
times sum which is an unfortunate
Collision I equals 1 to n w i j
x i minus mu J equals zero okay but then
because this is full rank the only way
that this thing is zero
is if it's identically zero right if
this were non-full rank sorry the J is
in the wrong spot that's extraordinarily
confusing
if this Matrix since this Matrix is full
rank for this thing to be zero means
that this blue part is identically zero
and so what that tells us is Mu J
should be equal to
sum I
w i j
x i
over
sum
w i j
yeah
that's before
okay
so
so far nothing happened we estimated the
means by simply averaging their weighted
averages and we computed this before and
it's just a matter of computing the
derivatives the one that I actually care
about showing you by the way is 5j so
let me just jump to that because we only
have a minute or two left and I want to
show you what happens in 5j so 5j is
constrained
please
sure
okay sure also I would say you know
ahead of time I do post all the notes
online please feel free to take a
reference to those notes too they will
have potentially fewer typos than me
trying to answer questions draw and
generally be distracted can't focus that
well I have to read them many times they
still do have typos though so always
look at the notes
all right let me just show this one
thing 5j is constrained okay so 5j is
constrained and I just want to remind
you of something that you probably
learned in high school or you know like
freshman year and calculus I don't
actually know when anyone learns
anything anytime I say something that my
students always get upset with me so I
should just stop but I assume you've
seen it before this moment about that
you need a lagrangian
okay
no you haven't seen it that's fine too I
will put if you want I'll post notes
about how to compute lagrangians as well
if you haven't seen this before this
will trip you up in some way so when you
compute the derivative with respect to
Phi J what happens is you're going to
get something that says you have this
weighted sum
w-i-j times uh the derivative of Phi J
log
Phi J
plus so if you just so if you just take
this and compute the derivative it
doesn't account for the constraint okay
so you have a bunch of numbers that must
sum to one so if you think about a if
you think about your honest you're on a
line let's say that you're optimizing on
a line right if the gradient like let's
say that your points are on are on this
line and you're saying like I want to
optimize here
this condition that you could imagine
for an optimal solution is the
gradient's identically zero right the
the advantages that's good that's a
point but what if the gradient is
perpendicular to the line like it wants
to push you only perpendicular and has
no component moving you along the line
right in that case this is still a
critical point it's still potentially a
minimum does that make sense because
it's not telling you that there's a
minimum to your left and right it's you
know along the line
okay so the question is how do you
encode that information that you don't
you want to kind of screen off
information that's orthogonal to the
line and I'll write up a little note to
show this this whole thing what you do
is you introduce this thing called
LaGrange multipliers and LaGrange
multipliers
and if you haven't seen them don't worry
these are super easy to teach just say
this
it's just an extra term here and this
multiplier it's not obvious in this
formulation what it's doing but this
multiplier is basically the thing that's
screening off things that are that are
that are uh orthogonal to these
constraints okay so this constraint here
says Theta J is equal to one and you set
this constraint equal to zero This this
term equal to zero and it says if you're
going off in a direction that that would
not change any of their values that's
okay you get to screen that off and I'll
make that geometric intuition I'll just
post a one-page write-up for you please
remind me in the thread and I will I
will definitely do that
if you don't do that you'll get the
wrong answer that's also a motivation to
learn it
um and so what ends up happening here is
you get something that says I get some I
goes from 1 to n w i j
over Phi of J
plus Lambda equals zero and this implies
that 5 of J is equal to 1 over Lambda
sum I equals 1 to n of w i j okay and
the Lambda is playing a very simple role
here it's just telling you like you have
to normalize them in some way
right now since
in this case we can do it in an ad hoc
way
since Phi J is equal to one this implies
the sum of Phi J
is equal to
negative 1 over Lambda sum
i j w i j
and this equals negative n over Lambda
okay and that's the correct
normalization right oh sorry this is
equal to negative n oh sorry n over
Lambda
right
and so now you can then go back and
normalize and cancel out the Divide
everything by one since this is just
this sum is equal to one I divide
everything by 1 here and that tells me
that Lambda must be equal to uh you know
1 over negative n
right this is equal to one
so this implies Lambda equals negative
one by n it's just normalizing it's just
doing the average which was weird to
look at before but that allows us to
compute all the things in the way we'd
expect here it's totally natural so if
you don't get the general rule that I'm
trying to tell you the reason I'm trying
to tell you is I think we make you use
it at some point this rule so just check
it'll come up on a homework I don't
think it comes on an exam but just flag
something when you have a constraint
when you have a constrained probability
distribution you have to use a LaGrange
multiplier that's all I care about that
you understand in this case it makes
total sense though because these numbers
have to sum to one so if you don't have
a normalization constant here you're
adding up a bunch of numbers which
individually sum up to n right the sum
over all of them is n you better
normalize them in some way and this is
just the principle that tells you you
have to normalize them by by this n
Factor
okay so all I care that you take away if
you've seen this a thousand times before
don't worry I hope you had a nice rest
if you've never seen this before I just
want a flag for you when you minimize a
function that's constrained make sure
you use LaGrange multipliers I will put
up a little tutorial about them you do
not need to spend a bunch of time on
them it's just if you see some challenge
where you're actually supposed to some
problem where you're supposed to do it
just have a little light bulb to go off
says okay I got to look up how to do it
in this case that's all I care about
okay and you'll Trace through it in the
notes please
[Music]
yeah it equals to minus sorry equals
minus 1 over n because there's a
negative sign everywhere so this minus
Lambda is going to be equal to 1 by n so
I'm just going to write the final
expression maybe that'll be less
sorry oh this this arithmetic is what's
bothering you sorry sorry this is true
yeah yeah sorry I just swap them and
even that's backwards from how I should
do it I didn't see that sorry thank you
right it's just supposed to average out
so it looks the same
awesome
any questions about this
all right
because it's a probability distribution
so again the issue here is Phi J is
constrained by the model so if we go
back to this model this is a constraint
on Phi J so whenever you have a
probability distribution a multinomial
probability distribution it's not just
that the Phi eyes are non-negative which
is the constraint we're almost ignoring
but is that the Phi eyes equal one and
so you couldn't for example set your
probabilities to be 0.5 and 0.8 right
they have to add up to one here because
it's a multinomial so when we do the
optimization we could for example prefer
an optimization where we make all the
probabilities one but that would be an
invalid setting and so that means these
five J's we have constrained them oops
constrain them to equal to one so now
the question is when we do the gradient
descent which is exactly the gradient
descent we did before where does that
show up and it shows up in this extra
term here which is the LaGrange
multiplier this thing is called a
LaGrange multiplier
the multiplier itself is called that
okay and this is the constraint put into
the normal form if you haven't seen this
before it'll look quite mysterious but
what I was trying to do is I'm not going
to teach you LaGrange multipliers in
this class I'll put up something but the
piece is here that it gets you back to
an expression which makes sense in this
setting and you needed something to
average over because these numbers sum
up to something that looks like n if you
just compute it naively you'll get
something that doesn't make any sense
please
no no there's no Sigma in here Sigma
like for solution
uh no in this setting the sigma's out
here
I think what's confusing you maybe is
this that these are not the same J's
which which line
oh oh oh I see I see I see I see sorry
sorry
yeah I was talking while I was saying
thank you for the clarification that was
really helpful
apologies for that yes it's this
constraint here sorry this is the
constraint that was in our head
yeah yeah and it just makes a mysterious
reappearance here
all right awesome
okay so what is the message that I want
you to take away from this two things
first message is
GMM is an em algorithm
okay
that's really you know one of the the
pieces that is there and this is
interesting because we're going to see
in the next lecture we're going to see a
different example which is called factor
analysis where Z has a very different
form and it's meant to constrain the
problem in a different way
we went through in this lecture a couple
of different steps we started with that
convexity piece so we could get an
intuition for what these functions look
like we didn't want to use convexity we
use concavity and then we went through
the EM algorithm which we formalized as
kind of back and forth with using these
curves over time
once we had those curves what was
happening was we would pick and optimize
on those curves and we were getting
these qis right the qi's played a
starring role those became our W's here
and they kind of add nastiness to all of
the equations but not a tremendous
amount of nastiness right they just add
little weights and expectations
everywhere and then we ran exactly the
kind of like you know standard
supervised machine learning if you like
or the stuff that you've been doing for
mle for the entire quarter on those
those properties then we introduced a
ton of typos to keep you on your toes
now I introduced on typos because I was
talking while I was writing and I
shouldn't have done that and so then we
saw the two things that I cared about
you highlight one is you know how to
find means and these are just weighted
means and you should run through that
calculation to make sure you know how to
do it because I'm almost positively will
ask you to do it at some point in the
near future and then the second thing
that I would tell you to do is when you
have constraints you have to know how to
optimize them you don't need to know the
general theory of how you optimized
against non-linear constraints but you
should review how to do this when you
have something that some still want it's
not more complicated than what I wrote
here but make sure independently you go
through it and ask questions I'm happy
to ask questions I'm happy to point you
for to different resources
in the next class as I said what we're
going to see is this notion of factor
analysis and that is going to tell us
how to apply em to a to a different kind
of setting which at first glance will
look like kind of impossible to do
without a latent variable model and it's
a pretty interesting scenario
um and I think that's all I want to say
any last questions before we head out
I'll stick around for a couple minutes
as usual thanks so much for your time
and attention